need motivation watch at opt-in with
believe nation what's that believe
nation it seven I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons of a woman who went from
growing up in poverty and being molested
as a child to becoming the queen of all
media and the most influential woman in
the world
she's Oprah Winfrey and here's my take
on her top 10 real success vol 5 also if
you want to know what Oprah and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence that
link the charring is in the description
below key to success is what you believe
is true for yourself your number one job
is to become more of yourself figure out
where your power base is
okay let's take it off with rule number
one know who you are for me the
foundational base of empowerment of
entrepreneurship of any kind of
engagement the foundational base of my
success of my well-being my wholeness my
everything is knowing who I am and where
I come from in my living room right now
is a painting that I've owned now for
thirty years you can google it it's
called to the highest bidder and it's at
the center of my house and it's at the
center of my house because it actually
is symbolic of the foundation of not the
house but the foundation for my life the
painting is by Harry Roslyn who was a
genre painting painter in the early
twentieth 19th century and the painting
is over six feet tall
and it shows a slave woman on the
auction block holding her daughter's
hand and I cannot come in the door my
front door or I cannot leave without
passing that painting I am reminded of
where I come from every day of my life
and I am reminded because I never want
to forget it and in my library I have a
frame list of enslaved African American
people remember I showed you who were
held in bondage on various plantations
listed in the Ledger's alongside the
cows and the horses and the buggies and
the other property and I pass this list
every day and often I stop in front of
it and just speak their names out loud
and their ages Jonah's eleven years old
five hundred dollars Sarah forty-one
years old
nine hundred dollars Elizabeth
57 $800 and I force myself to consider
the absurdity and the obscenity of
prices being affixed to each one should
they be placed up for sale and I
sometimes just pause before them with a
prayer particularly before I have to
make a big decision about one of my
companies or whether I booth forward or
whether I stay still it reminds me
speaking those names out loud not only
of where I've come from but how far I
have to go because of them and it
reminds me that I am never alone it
reminds me of what I've come through to
get through rule number 2 be a Warrior
of Light
everybody is feeding yourself on the
hysteria and the negativity you've gotta
stay in the light but one of the reasons
why I was so excited is about a wrinkle
in time because the message is that the
darkness is spreading so fast these days
you must become a warrior of the light
and the reason that's so meaningful to
me is because that's how I've led my
whole life and every moment in that film
I just felt like I'm just saying what I
don't know is that and and for these
times the darkness is there to show you
your light look at what has happened so
if you put the focus on look at what
happened with the darkness it showed up
in parkland and the darkness it showed
up on the streets of Ferguson then the
darkness that showed up in many many
many many many many homes in Chicago
with shootings and senseless murders it
brings out the best in people it brings
out the best and so that's what it's
there we live on a planet where there is
darkness and light what I deeply believe
is not that do unto others as you would
have them do unto you what you do is
already done that moment in the color
purple' where she says everything you
ever tried to do to me where Whoopi says
that 'silly everything you ever
everything you even tried to do to me
already done
you so the law the third law of motion
and physics says that what you're
putting out is coming back all the time
regardless of whether you know it or
acknowledge it or not so you got to stay
as a warrior kind of light rule number
three know your strengths I've done
magazines you've done movies you've done
television have you ever wanted to
release a CD of music oh honey please
[Applause]
no I you know what I think one of the
things I learned growing up watching
other people like Johnny Carson for
example was was a mentor in a way
because he always understood what he
could and could not do and I truly
understand that that is not something I
could do I mean I attempted it just as a
fun thing a couple years ago run on run
on I got stuck here myself that's why we
that's why we cut it off I wished I
could it's the one thing I wish I could
do but I think it's a gift to be able to
sing and that's not what I was given but
since I was given so many other rule
number four earned success my biggest
frustration is not just with young women
my biggest frustration is also with
young men young people who think that
and I have a lot of this with my girls
in college they think that success is
supposed to happen like the Attucks yeah
they think that there isn't a process to
it they think that they're supposed to
come out of college and have their brand
and I recognize now that I am a brand
but I was resistant to being called a
brand for many years because I was like
I'm brand I'm not a brand I'm a person
but how I got to be a brand was not
trying to be a brand how I got to be a
brand was every day making choices that
felt like this is the right move now
that's the right move and now that's the
next right move the next right move
and so my frustration with young women
and young men is that they think it's
supposed to happen
like this and they don't understand that
there's a process to it social media
media you did not get to be editor
Vogue magazine by not working and
working and working and working and
working to get here I love the theory of
that there's 10,000 hours behind anybody
who ever gets to be successful
number five have good intentions I was
interviewing a woman on one of the shows
of so impressive for me to see all the
shows that we've done Lord make me tired
looking at it but I was interviewing a
woman it was a show called the mistress
the wives meet the mistresses or some
crazy thing and this woman was on and it
was a live show and in the middle of it
her husband tells the wife and our
entire audience and the world that his
mistress was pregnant yes to this day
makes my eyes water because I saw his
wife's face and I felt her humiliation
and I said I will quit TV if I have to
do this I won't do this anymore and my
producers like what are we gonna do this
is what everybody's doing and then that
same during that same time period so I
said I'm not gonna do anything like that
anymore I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
bring people on TV where's the wood wall
but we didn't know that moment was gonna
happen they were like we didn't know was
gonna happen but that should not happen
on television and I do not want to be a
part of the energy that caused somebody
to feel that because that's now gonna
come back to me I got to pay for that
then I was interviewing the KKK on stage
that was the day the one guy called me a
monkey in the audience and during
commercial break I could see them
signaling each other and just watching
them and their behavior I thought oh
they get it I don't get it they are
using me they're using this platform
because they understand because I'm
thinking oh I'm gonna tell you all about
the KKK they were using it to recruit
members for themselves they were using
it to recruit their base and I then went
to the brewery sister said I'm not doing
a show like that so they say you know
gonna do the mistress's you know you
know KK what we gonna do so I said we
are going to create a baseline for
ourselves that's based on intention this
was around 1989 when I'd read Gary
zhukov's book called the seat of the
soul and that book was life-changing for
me because in it he talked about the
power of intention and that cause and
effect what goes out comes back is
determined by your intention the energy
of your intention is what determines
your life most people don't think about
their intention they just think about
what they wanted to most people don't
think about why they want to do it but
what's going to come back to you the
energy that's going to come back to you
is the real why of why you did it and so
I then said to my producers we're not
going to do any shows that are not
intentional so don't bring me an idea
unless you have an intention for the
show that you want the outcome to be and
we're gonna strive to see if we can live
up to our intentions and so around the
late 80s we started a pre-show to talk
about what the intention was and then a
post show after every single show to say
did we fulfill that intention and that's
about the time I realize this is bigger
than me rule over six love your audience
I actually miss I miss you guys yeah I
don't like this you know
because where I got fed every day was
the audience and I did not miss a day in
25 years because of the audience I don't
care how badly I felt I don't care what
kind of coal what kind of I would come
because I knew that our uri rod in our
audience every day were a couple hundred
three hundred and fifty people every day
who have literally told their aunts
their cousins they came with their
mothers they came with their friends and
I know that the preparation to get there
you've been coming from Iowa been coming
from Tennessee for days so it's not just
a oh I'm just going to Oprah show you
tag girl I'm going to open okay so rule
number seven just be yourself
the beauty of my life Edward is that
from might say 30 to 33 on I figured out
how to be myself completely on
television and all these years I have
made a fortune really being myself this
now so I'm never not me I'm never not
the person that you see you know there
are days when I am more open and warm
than others and one of the things that
actually caused me in 1991 to get my own
plane I was in the airport and I was
just minding my own business and a woman
came up and she said you're not acting
like you do on TV and I said what's that
she says well on TV you're hugging
everybody you just sitting here you're
not having anyway I'm just sitting here
man I'm just waiting on the plane so if
I'm in an airport I'm not necessarily
walking around hugging people okay but I
am I am just always just myself rule
number eight align yourself with your
dream life has dreamed a dream for you
and your your goal your number one job
is to figure out what that dream is and
align yourself with the dream because
the dream cannot come to you unless
you're willing to meet it energetically
in the same place so if your energy is
off which I say to my girls all the time
they could teach this class right now
being in flow if you are not in flow
with God's dream for you with life's
dream for you if you are out of order if
you are out of sync it cannot come to
you it will not come because the whole
purpose of your life is to line yourself
up with the purpose and so if you are
operating in fear if you are operating
in jealousy jealousy will kill you when
you are synched up with life life just
gives to you it opens doors
it creates experiences it allows you to
meet people things show up you never
thought we're gonna show up and you are
doing what is the purpose of your soul
being here ro Laren ein create a
meaningful life you know I believe that
the common thread that flows between and
through and around every person is that
we all have this deep desire within us
to create a meaningful life it's like a
yearning that we all have to be more
alive and to express ourselves and as
you think of what lasting fulfillment
looks like for you remember that this
force whatever name you may call it is
at work within you and all of us and it
has a bigger dream for you than you
could ever imagine for yourself and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is have fun I'm
really interested in my class is seeing
this now somebody's cell phone it is
like playing a little melody let's hear
it bring it over
come on come on come break oh come on
down who are you calling I'm Elaine is
it Elaine we just called you yeah you
know I can I actually called her to know
she wanted another son Oh mister didn't
return my car but she's calling now did
she answer at home
Elaine Elaine this is not a good time to
hit coffee Elaine Elaine this is Oprah
Winfrey and you call your friend while
she's sitting in the middle of an Oprah
Winfrey Show
no well this if she's sitting here right
now and she cannot believe that you
called her at this time where were you
were you Elaine did you know honest she
tried to call you earlier girl to come
to uh Michelle and you did not call her
back and so now you calling her while
she's sitting up here on the show you
know but no we're not on the TV now
we're tape the show the shows go what
time is it this is true of course it is
it sounds like me of course it is no I
wouldn't I wouldn't kid you with
something like that but anyway sorry you
missed today we were given away so much
stuff
the first law is the third law of motion
in physics which says for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
and we showed that very beautifully in
the color purple when Missy Lee says to
mr. everything you even try to do to me
is already done to you that is not just
a rhetorical saying that is law that is
Newton's third law of motion in physics
which says everything that goes out is
coming back it's just like everything
that goes up is coming down may take it
a long time to come down is coming down
everything that goes out is coming back
it's coming back ways your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
[Music]
passion not one drop of my self-worth
depends on Europe it's suppose to mean
if you like this video what more Oprah
check with the nine surprising facts
about Oprah Winfrey video that I did the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there and my name had been
chosen from the Bible my aunt Ida had
chosen the name but nobody really knew
how to spell it